hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Red Dead Redemption
too
we're on the road out of the wilderness
of the winter and we're on our way and
everything's gonna be great
everything's gonna be wonderful there's
obviously nothing that's gonna go bad at
any point in our life even though we
robbed a train and screwed over a deep
dark enemy that we all hinted at and
foreshadowed via untimely demise of
everybody in this party whatever the
rocks you say Oh
calm you say calmly the whooping oh no
the wagon horse got loose did you guys
know okay got it it's something about a
waterfall and whenever they put me in
charge or something I just can't help
but toss myself over the edge as soon as
I humanly can I'm sorry I'm never gonna
get through this game if if this is how
I'd do it
I gotta make sure that I do it right
love is if I go so fast can I Ram into
the other ones come on
get yeah go yeah oh yeah oh now come on
hip hair to do pee come on
I'm just working out a beat you know
it's getting kind of boring on the road
over here I just got to slab these
horses as best I can
oh that was real don't they so good come
on calm uh-huh unless we get ambushed
unless this is actually another tutorial
for fixing this thing because oh this is
this is
I'm trying I'm very weak I'm not strong
enough
yeah I was pretty close bamm-bamm horse
is what I'm out do to you once I get
back on that wagon that's what you
deserve horse
yeah it'll hold no need for a screw
nothing like that not yet anyway
oh there we go now there's a screw get
the tire iron on there uh uh uh problem
oh my spider senses are tickling I got a
problem problem I'm gonna go with the
problem poor bastards we really screwed
them over down here come on let's not
push our luck yeah okay all right why
it's the American there's the Native
Americans I'm sure that we treated them
fairly and everything was wonderful in
our history back in the 1800s
inland okay Raiders oh that's much yes
it's much more better information sports
got sold a very raw deal this is the
heartland you're going to good fireman
and Grayson country they lost it all
stolen clean away from them it was every
blade of grass killed or herded up to
the reservations in the middle of
nowhere and how is that different from
anywhere else oh maybe it's not I just
heard some of the army out here was
particularly unpleasant about it
unpleasant how do you rob and kill
people pleasantly we don't spotted I
just talk I fear I was perhaps trying to
simplify something more complicated for
the benefit of our blockheaded driver
here come on yeah forget this here's a
conman Charles born and bred just cuz it
sounds fancy don't mean he knows a damn
thing about what he's talking about
hmm well I don't know who to believe
anymore so what happened to your trap I
don't even know if I have one please not
that I can remember mm-hmm
my father was a colored man he told me
he live with our people for a while the
number of free men did when we were
forced to move from our lands three of
us fled I was too young to really
remember much oh I've been on the run
a couple years later some soldiers
captured my mother took us somewhere we
never saw her again we drifted around he
was a very sad man and the drink had a
mean hold on him around 13
I just took off on my own that was about
the age we found young art there here
maybe a little older a while there
delinquent you never did see Freddy
learn fast catch it
hottest fastest Marston apparently wait
I don't understand what's the problem
between you two on it there got a long
trip might as well tell it huh god damn
that's beautiful game
are we still head west in search of
fortune and repose in virgin forests as
we plan no are we heading in the correct
direction on our desperate escape from
the law eastwards down the mountains yes
I believe so you know this area hello
cap it through a couple of times there's
a livestock town not too far from here
called Ballentine cowboys outlaws
working girl's power kind of place
mistress
probably them two returns let's hope not
in this place we're going wait what's
the cold again horseshoe over them it's
a good place to lie low they'll do for
now mmm and how low do you think Dutch
is really going to lie it's just you
know maybe it's me who's changed not him
but we kept telling him that ferry job
didn't feel right you and me had a real
lead in Blackwater that could have
worked out maybe it just isn't like
Dutch to lose his head like that things
go wrong sometimes
people died miss the way it is always
has been me you Dutch we've all been in
this line of work a long time and we're
still here so I figure we must have got
a ride to hell a lot more than we got it
wrong hmm I don't know if I'm going the
right way
oh we're slowing down here hello oh well
bowl cereals and yarrow and ginseng good
for the hill better than that stuff you
buy in the store yeah you can have all
this I'm at the point where I can do it
with my eyes closed for me okay thank
you thank you I love me some herbs I
study or crash for some reason we just
stopped navigating automatically Hey
look dear she would get one be running
over ship yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh jeez
there's a lot more a lot more
off-roading than I think they intended
to do but we're gonna go for it
holy [ __ ] okay thank you which way this
way this way no oh no I'm off the trail
all right well giddyup
we gotta keep going come on let's get
adil we got places to be people to see
come on things to do
hello good Adal Oh God
there we go all right go go go any
minute now
you're real slow that's okay we don't
need to go anywhere I'm good it's not
like we have an agenda don't like people
are running from us
what are you tired of something can't
buck me off so what are you gonna do
about it okay guys
[Music]
hell yeah it's time to prosper Wow boss
blackwater
we're onto something big then Micah got
you all excited
that Farion here we are we have all made
mistakes over the years Hosea every last
one of us
but I kept us together kept us alive
kept the nooses off our neck I guess I'm
just worried how you got that long Dutch
I want folks safe before I go me too and
now we are stuck east of the Grizzlies
and out of money a long way from a dream
of virgin land in the West I know my
brother but we are safe we make a bit of
money here then we move again head out
around them be west of Uncle Sam in a
few months
buy some land I hope so would you just
look around you this world has its
consolations gentlemen
I am going to a head into the local town
and you know see if I can strike up a
little business of course hair Straus up
for robbing banks to usery seems more
dignified somehow
oh yeah sure yeah boss everyone put your
tools down for a moment come on gather
round
quickly now I know that things have been
tough but we are safe now and we are far
too poor so it is time for everyone to
get to work get to work but stay out of
trouble remember we are a tenor and work
laid off when they shut down our factory
to the north right out there and see
what you can find uncle Reverend Swanson
no more passengers it is time for
everyone to earn their keep there is a
town little way down the track name of
Valentine livestock town all mud and
morons if I remember right that seems a
decent place to start and uh we need
food real food that means every day one
of you and remember whatever it is that
you find the camp gets its slice
now be sensible out there okay your tent
ready mr. Morgan come with me oh thank
you
we put you over here should be most your
stuff from Blackwater got saved
everything apart from my money oh don't
remind me but you always make more money
we're gonna have to know oh god it's so
crazy how this does seem like to some
real community they see like it's
pulling each other up by their
bootstraps
chappie too for sure look also I really
like the way they're breaking up the
story as it was compared to the first
game because the first game was like
super like I don't know it felt like GTA
in the West which was good and bad in a
ball of ways like I didn't know any
different a couple of weeks a couple of
weeks later and but this one is just
like so fascinatingly like tight-knit
it's linear I get it is linear and
that's not forever but it seems a little
better
his eyes are sparkling once more I can
see he's thinking a little clearer I
think we all feel a little happier spot
of black water in that whole mess I
think those they're quite a day this
hope so there's a bunch of the boys
already in Valentine bill Charles and
heavier and Swanson found something down
at the train station by the lake
apparently and Strauss came back with
that creepy little smile on his face I'm
sure there's a whole list of
unfortunates he's for smiting a bomb
thank you yeah I'm gonna read a book oh
I love it
see this is what I meant when I was
gonna open up I believe there's missions
and stuff but now it's like completely
opened up and it's a whole world oh I
gotta I gotta take in this view here
because my good god oh my god oh my god
ha ha ha hey can I chop firewood nothing
nothing at all for the first time in
weeks
nothing we're free with free to plan our
own futures once more
I hope so Dutch you kept the faith or is
it you always kept it oh and there was
something about like my beard grows
longer as I go along I'm gonna chop this
wood because I can because if I've ever
wanted an exercise I wanted to be in a
place where I can chop my own wood even
though it's a chore and annoying I want
to do it cuz I'm a modern man and I have
no end conveniences in my life and I
thirst and yearn for adventure but
careful adventure in the form of a video
game
each day person will make a stew oh my
god I could just do this forever
couldn't hey it's not like the minigames
oh it's not like the minigames I've seen
where you get a little money for every
piece of firewood you chopped no that's
funny who's out here oh hey buddy how
are you doing how you doing oh my
morning whatever your name is how you
all right well no not much for come my
god can I do cinematic view while I'm
walking
um oh my god someone get their phone out
take a panorama this is beautiful holy
[ __ ]
oh my god this game is you know there's
been open-world games that are like half
good for us and whatnot but I mean
Skyrim obviously is the one that jumps
to mind but this one has a sense of
scale that I've never seen before and
now that we're finally actually free to
go do whatever we need to do I'm excited
to see where it's gonna lead but sadly
I've heard that this game is over 40
hours long so I'm not gonna be able to
do too many um what you McCall quests
and whatnot where is my map okay let me
hang on I'm gonna take a little second
here I'll figure out the controls of
this map here we go
[Music]
you uncle uncle uncle all right I'll go
to Uncle I don't know where that might
be but I'll go to Uncle when our
Marsten's doing hang on actually let me
go to this little little Health Plus
thing and maybe marcin's over there
morning Pearson here
Marsten oh oh you are prisoner oh holy
[ __ ] okay hello
how you doing you good hey buddy I got
you mr. Morgan hi how you doing I still
don't know your name
chickens I got to find I got to find it
Abigail Marsten's wife who I did your
Abigail right
aren't you Abigail Abigail Abbie alright
never mind that okay goodbye jeez man
cold shoulder here alright let's just
move on we don't have time to waste I
ain't gonna waste no time so I ain't
gonna do that
hello uncle uncle wake up you drunk
[ __ ] come on I don't know careful not
to work yourself to death there uncle I
was thinking how does it pay well Oh
eventually hmm so while the rest of us
are busy stealing killing line fighting
to try to survive you get to thing
called a strange world we live in
Arthur Morgan now you want to head into
town see if we can find anything else
sure I got some errands to run great go
check the horses are ready
grumble got a dual domain in town
take us to well you got planned nothing
we'll find something for y'all to do we
always do we're bored out of our minds
they cooped up here for two weeks now
Karen's about ready to murder Grimshaw
we can miss Grimshaw spare you can miss
Greenshaw spare you what's happening you
Arthur
three young healthy women want you to
take them a Robin you're worried about
house chores let's go alright
Oh ladies get ready to take a wild rough
yeah y'all yep yeah okay we're gonna
take as many off roads as we can watch
out for sharp turns hold a hunt through
your dear lady Oh God
I like that song it's one of my
favorites oh never mind let's keep going
all right cracking her pantsuits is that
you okay nevermind I'll go get it
Oh God I got I got it I got it I'm good
at this
oh hang on wait oh I got to speak to him
first what happens if I just go get it
what if I'm just one of them just a
baller shot caller Baal or Baal or Baal
or Baal or shot caller oh oh god no no
wait oh oh oh no that's I didn't mean to
do that the law were over everybody
ignore that that was uh that was not
supposed to happen that was one of those
not supposed to happen things it
happened he definitely did do half oh
god we gotta listen to the vagina song
again okay all right yeah yeah I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna do it now knocking a hog
time I swear to God the law ain't gonna
be alerted lumbago
Fran oh hey you couldn't help me get my
all the horse back from over there could
you uh I could help
helps bra I gotcha so I take it it
wouldn't take kindly to a lass sue I
mean I could last so it but somehow I
think it's gonna end badly for me
hey whoa oh I can do it alright hey whoa
hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa whoa whoa all
right show info yeah yeah well yeah whoo
yeah whoo whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa yeah
yeah whoa whoa come on Pat you I'm gonna
slap you slap you on the rump and give
you a few slaps here we go slap slap
city slapping ooh dot but back
blap-blap-blap all right here we go come
on come on now come on now let's get
over here me and my big beard is it my
beard that really entices you yeah
you're a pretty horse ain't you
our handsome feller lady I'm not sure
either way you're handsome I know right
ladies I'm pretty impressive if I do say
so myself and I am saying so I think you
might be a lady so I'm gonna treat you
right you handsome horse lady anyway I
got your horse sorry I was being weird
on the way back you know this is the way
I am trying to impress the women just
trying to impress a women
the horses takes a massive [ __ ] all over
the place okay guys alright this is my
fast walk hope you don't mind it let's
get back on here
oh yeah like I said before this game is
like 40 plus hours I'm gonna play all of
it
so get ready for like a twenty part
series all two hours are
[Music]
beep-beep-beep beep-beep-beep
thank you nice do any real work okay
baby baby baby baby baby beep alright
lady wait wait how do i back this thing
up how do we go backwards in a horse
there we go here we go hi hey how you
doing everybody oh my god it seems it's
like do I look like a young man to you
just remember keep a low profile well
you remember that thou art probably not
let's park up down the end there near
the stables God it feels so real
maybe beep beep beep beep oh hey how's
it going there
excuse me yellow shirt man it is finest
we're gonna do what any self-respecting
maniac does what the women to work with
pleasure we'll start at the saloon okay
just stay out of trouble and don't get
yourselves noticed right I need to get
something from the stores okay we'll see
you at the general store when you're
done come on
so that's how you see yourself is it a
maniac
in my youth I used to be known as the
one shot kid okay I'm not gonna ask why
you are a sad man Arthur Morgan but I
know you love me - brutally you're my
favorite pair sir no ring wars my
favorite pair set you're my second
favorite pair sir very funny hmm
I'll add ringworm then rats with the
plague then you shut up here's the place
huh come on
so what do you need tail or drop a
whiskey for a start it's not gonna pass
the time while we're waiting on women I
got beans
here's the door well you got a catalog
do I even need to go around
god it's like real life it's real life
everybody it's real life hunting fishing
for horse care Wow zoom haha Wow yeah Oh
buddy Oh mom oh yeah lover Santa lotion
[Music]
the Lambs the best in the state
I know what the smell is cheese all
right wait potent horse stimulant fire
up your horse like never before
hmm do not be cruel to your horses bass
national attention to their manure and
conduct routine inspection and fecal egg
counts okay all right I'm gonna buy some
horse stuff I don't know what its gonna
do but I've got it now whatever that
means
okay clothing I probably need to take
off my coat aren't I boiling hot and
whatever it's fun
do I need coffee where's the coffee
where's the coffee fee anybody uh
whatever who needs it okay old man I got
what I needed
horse stimulant horse tranquilizer for
low and down the stimulant absolutely
he's a funny world it's time my career I
pictured
myself being married to an heiress Oh
what did I just take a nap snuck into
this fancy house acted like a servant
girl usually works someone was saying
her sister was taking a trip from New
York or someplace train full of rich
tourists heading to Santa knee and then
cruising off to Brazil okay a train
laden with baggage and passing through a
bit of deserted country at not as to get
to the docks in time for the tabs in
some place called Scarlett Meadows hotel
they were picking up some drunken
fellows that they was gonna rob why it
seemed easy I have been gone for quite a
while
oh yes I'll go see if there's any
trouble oh there's Tilly over there just
not look ideal excuse me oh well time to
beat some people up all right I got
wingus and Inga's here ready to fight
[Music]
whoa hey whoa hey whoa let's see what
you gonna do some more wood exactly or a
whole lot of dis body what're you gonna
do now we're gonna do now you're making
a big mistake to the Jackson just across
the street okay thanks
you're welcome sorry I've pointed a gun
at you for a second but I promise I was
pointing at him just in case all right
well now the guy that got taken care of
Karen what are you up to in that hotel
here we go what are you doing up there
Karen Karen Karen what's going on in
here I better not walk into anything
unsavory Karen just gonna stare at you
for a little bit and then wander off to
the ride farewell farewell like the
music no no no trouble no trouble why
would there be any trouble why would
anybody have any trouble oh yeah get
ready for I'll wait hang on I forgot out
a punch there we go oh-ho okay you sure
yeah nothing doesn't worry about just
man but stupid bastard stupid bastard
was boasting about the bank bank sure I
know small town banks are usually a
waste of time but there's the livestock
town there's lots of cash sometimes okay
keep investigating I will then
alright then keep investigating I
suppose oh yeah listen if you see a guy
passed out on the floor it's because I
did a real good job knew him wink wink
wink wink Wong Thank You Arthur
what I don't much like being safe when I
have to be
you okay sure you only punched me aren't
the punch team a lot harder
weren't you in Blackwater a few weeks
back me no sir ain't from there you were
well I definitely saw you with a bunch
of fellers me no impossible listen buddy
come here for me I saw you come here
cool
I don't like this me neither I gotta go
after we get the girls home I'm gonna go
have a word with our friend I'm gonna
last soon just a word just the word just
send us conversation me with my fists
wingus and dingus this rope a whole lot
of time oh yeah I've completely lost it
he's not a man oh that we use on my
mini-map okay it's a red circle there
hey hey come on buddy
we just want to talk I just want to talk
me and my six friends want to talk
that's all six of my fingers about to
introduce you to a world of pain that
you ain't never seen before all right
all right all right hey hey yeah well
you shouldn't have recognized me huh you
shouldn't have point at me in the middle
of the street oh wow all right now
listen now listen now listen what did
what were you uh are you doing please
help I never been in black water didn't
why are you chasing me I've got an
unfortunate face yes please pull me up
please
well alright geez I can't just let
someone fall to their death if I could
prevent it but you listen you and me
just cuz I'm a nice guy doesn't mean
that I like you okay partner no well
yeah that's clear you shouldn't even be
around here by the look at ya is that
correct I think it's best for both of us
if we pretend this never happened well I
agree you saved my life
you're a good man and I hear you want a
pen it's one of them steel ones no
that's very kind of you hmm but I'm not
a good man Jimmy Brooks and I usually
you see I was in Blackwater I kill
people and maybe I should have killed
you should I have killed you Jimmy
Brooks I never saw you no not now not
never I think we have an understanding
of course we do
Jimmy Brooks I will remember that I've
got a good memory haven't not not one
lick in this year old man that was the
scariest thing I've ever heard I'm so
that was so much better than just
killing him straight out that was so
cold-blooded thing I've ever witnessed
in the history of ever forever so busy
okay
I gotta go back holy [ __ ] okay anyway
sorry I'm just blown away by that
interaction there that's another thing
about this is like goddamn good good
writing can I can I create a waypoint or
something like that yeah there we go
alright there we go god I mean god damn
that was vicious so I'm just gonna I'm
gonna be reeling from that for a cook
good long while it just like that guys
gonna remember that for the rest of his
life
I got his pen I took his soul with me
who was this 10 of a circus in town whoa
yeehaw all right okay I can't just cat
Kansas pass this up I have no idea what
this is but I need to know what the show
is I'm gonna put down money and you're
gonna show me a show oh wait did they
have anything like this at this time
this is 1899 did they actually have
projectors and stuff to tell about the
woods of Massachusetts and the creatures
that live there maybe one of summer a
bear was by the stream I shall blow a
mighty cold upon the land and gorge
yourself on fish and meat and go find
the den then sleep not for one night
for 60 go tell all the animals of the
forest what I have told you there was
sad because the fish was friends and now
the animals of the forest often teased
bear and said he was slow sure about
this 1899 I don't know it's not really a
movie it's a slide show and they're
giving the illusion of a movie oh maybe
that is something okay that's pretty
impressive
okay anyway I got to get back
excuse me sorry pardon me excuse me ma
beebeep huh sorry sorry
uh-oh
crime reported listen listen listen
listen guys listen I'm not I listen it's
okay I give up I surrender I surrender I
surrender I surrender
maybe I shouldn't have done that I
didn't mean to hit anybody with my horse
but admittedly oh [ __ ] look it was an
accident I swear
oh [ __ ] here I go getting older god damn
it I really screwed up
am I better now am I better I'm all good
gonna go thanks for nothing this is my
horse horse all right so I guess I gotta
get back you I can gain and lose weight
oh my god there's a question there but I
want to go back to the camp we need to
talk to Hosea
all right can I you can't fast travel I
bet I bet there's not really gonna be
fast travel in this one I don't think
that was fast travel in the first one I
think it was like yet I'm sorry look
listen listen look I don't know what
voice view I got going on here but you
guys better watch out I'll become the
horse
I am the horse excuse me sir Oh God yeah
there we go all right okay can I please
did I almost get hit by a train I bet I
did okay so am I going the right way I
think maybe I'm holding it so I can only
admit yeah it's going good okay so I'm
gonna go back to the camp I do want to
go hunting that is something that I do
enjoy about this game so what I'm
probably gonna do is I'm gonna at least
get one deer so I can string it across
the back of the horse I bet they've
taken out like the unlimited hunting of
the last one where you can just get like
skin after skin and loaded in your pouch
until you're loaded up with like ten
thousand pelts and I bet they did that
also because I bet there's like a
realistic economy in here where you
can't actually get like an incredible
amount of money like that getting money
is gonna be hard you got to make tough
choices if you want to make money it's
gonna kind of leave you to making moral
decisions and oh my god
why is that so beautiful why it's so
pretty oh my god that's so pretty can
you imagine
10 years ago that we would get a game
this god oh sorry that's that's what I
wanted okay let me switch out of this
real quick okay let me I need to get do
I have my bow on this one I do okay let
me get the bow cuz I'm gonna go get this
horse where was that
track that one I'm shocked I remember
that oh I got me a squirrel okay good
for me then I guess hey it flies all
round it already that's a bunch of BS
all right so that I know where was that
gosh darn no don't tie by in the tree
what are you trying to hide from the
squirrels at a horse well that's a horse
oh nevermind then that's not helping
anybody god dammit I there was a deer
here now there's no deer and I feel
stupid cuz I'm wasting time cuz I'm
trying to Hon we'll just keep our eyes
out for more deer on the way if they get
near by we'll catch him but if not then
we won't worry about too much I don't
know where that one deer ran off to you
Oh God it seems like it's seems like it
might actually be hard to hunt alright
what a big waste of my time hey guys I
got a squirrel hope you're proud of me
you're real proud of a good good
squirrel hey how are you doing hey
what's up hunting you wanna go huntin
yes what yes I do
elephant I wish no I saw a huge bear
I reckon nearly a thousand pounds my god
you made me to come with you of course
let's go where we hadn't exactly up near
the Dakota River might take a day or two
I can do with a break from this place
me too it's been a rough couple of weeks
you need anything I don't think so I got
all on me let's go there oh yeah replace
Boadicea oh I miss her she was quite a
horse this one's okay ain't no boat to
see me no bodacious big shire horse for
a while now I'm Rudy bastard where'd you
get him some big loudmouth bastard tried
to Robin was out riding so I let's take
him to Valentine it's on the way Sardar
there's a decent dealer there well
unload him you could buy yourself a new
horse put your saddle on them let's get
good saddle okay well you don't know
that all right it's gonna be fun you
said he was an unruly bastard he's big
he's big
oh he's big let me give him some good
Pat's a bat back he's big boy he's a big
boy
he's a big boy who's a big boy huh who's
a big boy boy we'll use a big boy all
right all right back to Valentine I
suppose
range a horse tack at the Valentine
stables some beautiful saddles I used to
have a real nice one yes remember back
when crazy threatened to kill the whole
town and Davey was passed out so cold we
left him there came back in the next day
and he woke up started right back
drinking again
[Music]
those boys laugh Lenny and Jenny could
never have worked
that's like Arthur and Martha makes
sense no ship name in there
maybe you're right yet they're still
very hot need to be done right
alright well let's get over to the car
dealership and offload this vehicle
unreal
oh hey whoa hey whoa whoa whoa
the unruly unruly Shh I just whispering
sweet nothings in your ear just you're
such a big boy you've got such a shiny
coat it doesn't matter that you've got
some spots of brown you're just a black
beauty to me hmm
oh you're so pretty I love the way your
rump jiggles as we run slap slap love
the sturdiness of your neck good boy
oh do good boy that's a good boy oh good
boy good boy good boy who wants to go
into stable in this ominously litt man
hey you want a big honking horse oh how
can I help you that's a big horse I'm in
the market for a new horse something
strong and fast yeah well you're in the
right place I got some beauties in at
the moment yeah what about this one here
are you looking to sell I sure you you
got papers no no papers yeah of course
that's gonna affect what I can pay but
your Luck's in I got a fella who's been
looking for a decent work horse like
this for a while and pay a good price
otherwise I can always stable them here
for you yeah
take a look oh I will take a look what's
them what's up miles per gallon on these
bad boys here ooh
sure so five bucks five bucks for a big
honking horse like that I'm gonna regret
this but I'm going for it I'm going
goodbye Oh
$65 never mind that was totally fine
Dutch warm blood I don't like the look a
Dutch hardness foot was zero dollars why
is this one zero you know I want our
Dennis I don't know why I get Arden this
for free but I'm getting hardness okay
hang on
everybody I - wimple and she won't bow
hey stumpy any tacking services Hudak Oh
saddles oh yeah oh all right yeah okay
all right I like oh my god that is gaudy
I love it it's a little bit of Wharf
stash improved it is improved
oh it's vastly improved oh I love how
horrible this one is though wait what
have we got here Oh Oh terrible it's
weathered I don't know why that's good
oh my god
how's it go standard it's fine I got it
all right
oh yeah Oh saddlebags what uh can I love
crazy saddlebags you know I want that
[ __ ] oh yeah Oh give me the ugly one
well that was hideous I love it let me
get the big ones biggest ones you got oh
oh
safety strip for me I'm a big boy I need
my safety stirrup with schwoop oh he's
gonna make me feel real safe All Right
Scoop oh good god here's a horn give me
the biggest hole what's the ugliest
blanket that we ever did see
I think it's already come with the ugly
one yeah it looks all ratty
let's get you some good swamp oh you
deserve the best wimple I can't afford
the best but you deserve it
unless you can think about that I guess
I could have looked at the colors but
are we going bed rolls whatever you got
wool padded canvas got the padded so
that's good enough for me oh it looks
good
the braid wit color we can dye your hair
haha oh god dammit I didn't color it
properly there we go
ah stupid Dale services what have you
got horse care package it's like the
additional warranty it's trying to
upsell me on the horse warranty for
stimulant Odin horse stimulant
potent medicine potent horse medicine
alright I am officially out of money
I've spent I'm gonna love this horse
forever I'm gonna love you swoop oh
you're my baby schwump oh yeah your
papers on me a new grooming brush had
some treats you you treat this fellow
well I know he's gonna look after you
just fine I love this horse with all my
life I got well okay well see you swoop
cioppino scruple come back oh yeah
alright cool let me just nuzzle your
neck they're dancing which might be
[Music]
yeah back into the mountains I sure
didn't figure on that you know what I
just noticed
Jason you know I just noticed things
with you and John they yell when they're
far apart automatically time you let it
go now
it was a year Jose he ditched us for a
god damn you I've spoken to him many
times he knows he did wrong he just
wants to put it behind me I'm sure he
does running off on that kid is one
thing but there's cold
he knows that getting Trelawny
dusting you pretty much raised I know
but it's done has been for a while now
nobody else would have been welcome back
that easy after that long and you know
it baby
but please don't you put that to the
test I never would
yeah they shout at each other they
raised their voices when they were
across like on the other side of the
barns and then they automatically went
back to normal speaking voice is when
they were close to each other how do
they do that
how do they do that when the voice
actors have to record all these lines
did they record multiple versions of
each one and then that's so much
recording that's so much work how would
they ever do that that's insanity
this beyond dancing
stop marveling about it alright go get
us a bear oh I guess we're done looking
at that I don't know what we're looking
at now besides okay that's supposed to
happen okay whatever you say
you know a pond good for you our guess I
don't know ponds
you want another boy few kisses you
won't get smoochy-smooch on your next
football alright swoop oh you're going
gage boom boom I'm gonna get all the
kisses in love in the world I love you
swing go good boy good boy I love you oh
look at its wumpa branson mumbles oh
happy - your boy - your boy maybe we
should catch one to cook
sure try shoot one you don't want to use
anything too powerful on a small animal
like that just ruin the meat you don't
know that 22-caliber varmint rifle I
hunted rabbits before yeah well that's a
little rude and very accurate where's my
bow oh no wait that's not what I wanted
to do oh I can have more than one now
that's Andy okay so let me get the Mambo
out I'm gonna get my rabbit vision in
where are we going this really just
teaching me to live off the land I know
but I'm still getting used to good thing
I've got super glowy eyeballs that are
able to know exactly were these animals
all right this one went so far
where did you go dear oh well God tit oh
wait no it's still there okay
celebration flop hmm
just one get you good all right let's
kinam no really not oh wait here we go
wait no I need that rabbit meat of that
okay whatever
okay well this has been fun
okay just getting mine shoulder nice and
bloody now I guess I could have waited
to skin it until we got back but
whatever yeah whatever you didn't do
nothing you want it
wreck we should camp here all right
all items camp goddamn why God do
everything okay we'll do it right here
on this nice rock okay there we you just
got to be quick about it I don't know
why it's supposed to be like that but
you got to be quick as soon as you're
done why'd you hesitate on delicious
it's so cool like the whole first few
hours is game is teaching like this is
how you live in the woods effects
ingredients okay here we go
just take it all right there you go
I don't need a stick or nothing and all
right good enough for me cook another
I'll cook another what hell I'll cook
another I guess I could cook it for
later otherwise it is gonna spoil in my
in my bag but yeah whatever I don't know
that for sure I don't know how this game
work hi accurate could it possibly be
right all right we're good what else we
got
first like to find this monster maybe
it'll find us cuz we're sleeping Con out
in the open air
you know nobody around alright I'll
sleep till morning I guess how much
drama going on here just good old time
with buddies going camping kind of nice
just watching the clouds go by God even
that's nice even that's pretty morning
up you ready give me a minute
coffee sure there you go sure what a
strange of life so what's your play well
you'll see if we can track him but we
might need to lay bait to draw him out
bears like fish obviously but they also
have a sweet tooth now Laura fellows
bake then shoot from the trees but I
prefer to hunt on the ground more
dangerous but we'll have a much better
chance of getting good shot in and if he
bolts we can start right off after him
can you mix up this bit for me while I
finish packing this up fish berries I
tie it up in that rag when you're done
that was virtually weaned on bear meat
okay you got it body happy to help
time to go okay let's go yeah but I was
I was listening like God what a weird
look oh my god my horse
such a weird life just living day to day
every day you know I was in this area
I imagine you still miss her everyday
did you two ever think about getting out
of the lot now we did briefly you don't
remember
yes you were still young didn't last
long I drifted back into it she
understood she knew what I was around
for a while things were loose you're
back then truth is there's never really
any gettin out staying in it's hard you
know that the Bessie and I made it work
why you thinking about getting out Hey
no course not
listen if Dutchess grand plans work and
we can make enough money to go someplace
new really new
maybe we can all have a new start anyway
for now let's try and chase ourselves a
bear shall we let's look by the water
here see if he's been fishing again
recently yeah he's about to give fishing
berries and bullets all recipes stuff
you gotta give me a big gun are you
gonna let me shoot at him with this
little 22 that ended up killing me a
while back Boosh let me look with my
special eyes I don't you live tripping
balls there was something in that rabid
meat and it is uh really messing with me
ah boy howdy this is some fish this
probably ain't the bet yeah they do
let's hope it's him can you tell which
way he went no cuz I'm dumb oh yeah wait
no my intelligence is kicking up gonna
focus on this
Oh big the bear I like when the music
it's all almost like that okay but quiet
down I need to concentrate to be able to
bring this bear down it's gonna be a
doozy of a bear whoa is this poop is
that poop only half leave a fish okay
maybe we should just find the bear oh
how about that why don't we just find
bear shoot bear eat bear Oh poop please
tell me this poop all right what happens
if I walk right through it squish all
right no comment on that one no comment
on how I just led you to scooch on some
bear turds okay whatever
we lost him for now a little optimist
and either no well what do you think I
think we split up and each look either
that or we could place bait here that
could work which do you think I think we
should you use the bait we got if we
split up it'll just Maul one of us to
death let's bait here fine by me
let's leave the bag over there splitting
up seems like the goddamn worst idea
that you could possibly do you do that
alright let's do this right here oh yeah
holding bear trap there we go right
there easy peasy
can I climb up on these no I can't okay
I got this wait where's my gun I'm good
okay see nerves
[Music]
let's you don't need to look at the bait
why would you need to look at the bait
we're right here looking at the bait we
only just said it Jose
I know but we need to do this right well
then why didn't you do it why you got to
criticize me doing the bait and you
you've got a look at the bait I don't
got a look at the bait you've got a look
at the bait look at your boy before I
look at the bait Oh see
oh no this this is exactly what I was
concerned about
[Music]
[Applause]
well hey did you run away like a little
[ __ ] baby you're fine oh man
of course I'm fine nothing nothing thank
you I think that was fun you know what
either Morgan I'm a little old and
beaten up to me after the biggest game
you can have this back a man in a bar
gave it to me
well I stole it from him but that's
another story he said it told him where
to find some real big animals thank you
it's a pleasure you saved my life Arthur
I think I'm going back to camp to lick
my wounds you coming
you're gonna track that monster well oh
boy I'm gonna stay I'm gonna kill that
bear Oh stick around here for a while
I'll see you back at camp maybe you want
to lend me the big gun that might be
might be helpful if you lend me the big
gun if you if you let me the big gun
that might be elbowing me killing a big
bear okay you'll never see me ever again
I can examine ooh flowers these will be
good for John Marston he'll really
appreciate a wild carrot what the hell
really okay easy enough then hey Bubba
hey simple you want a carrot there
swampy bumpy
you wanna you wanna brush you washy huh
can I brush your dish I brush your dish
no look at you look at you oh what a
cutie okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna get this get this this and that so
that I can have what I need
that way I need to start hunting you say
here Bubba
I'm gonna go catch this bear Betsy I'm
gonna get this bear I'm probably gonna
do probably extremely gonna die but at
least I'll go down fighting a big ass
bear and that's you know that's
something remember more poop oh yeah my
favorite type of editor dense buzzer
linear I must be says you anyway let me
get my big gun out here what the hell
train I thought we were in the middle of
absolutely nowhere huh it just ends here
well we willwe wolf oh [ __ ]
oh wait break free oh my god oh my god
oh my god
oh okay
holy [ __ ]
holy crap holy crap in a crap basket
what the hell hey horse don't mind the
gigantic bear carcass hey horsey troppo
can you come over here um Wow okay then
I lost my hat
yeah yeah no kidding I lost my hat so am
I gonna get any meat from this bear or
don't mind what's on your butt right now
any meat from this thing or is that just
just you know whatever I guess we'll
just leave that there
yeah okay waste not want one all right
boys let's get out of here swampy I
don't know where we are and I don't know
why we're here I don't know where my hat
is where'd my hat go well where my head
it's gotta be on the crown right I gotta
get my hat yeah I know it's not pleasant
to look at either yeah I guess I just
got to get new hat got these bear wounds
yeah and I please like I don't know
there we go drink one of these up ah
that's more like that's what I am
talking about this is nothing nothing
here's some bear wounds like snake oil I
guess all right where the hell am I and
why am i all the way out of here
whoop a bear is done holy [ __ ] I am far
far far away
okay so what's over here Xavier escuela
and Reverend Swanson Jose I told you
that Swanson found something down the
train station by the lake and then
Xavier is over here Xavier hosea told
you that Javier bill and Charles were
already in Valentine
okay well I can go there but boy howdy
is that gonna take a while is there any
way to fast travel
there's no way to fast travel right I
don't think there is any way well I
don't think there's any way to fast
travel so oh no I think we just got to
go there holy [ __ ] alright then if
that's what it is and that's the game
alright let's mosey our way down but I
think for the first time in a while
we're kind of free I don't know what I'm
looking for and frankly okay thank you
sir let's go to go first it's good to
take a straight line to my destination
no matter what
a little bit a little it's pretty guys
why is it so pretty
rocks that sounds nice but I don't want
ducks at the moment all right I'll be
back once that be oh I'll be back once I
figure out how to get to my destination
yep oh wait no my Pelt
wait no no wait whoa I abandoned my Pelt
oh god my Pelt fell off oh where did I
hit that tree oh god damn it
Oh what okay all right okay
whoa-ha-ha Mountain nanhua beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful
says who oh I see what's going on you
might wanna
oh sorry dude
shouldn't be kidnapping people maybe Oh
all right now all right now hello I'm
doing it I'm doing it okay should I put
you on my horse or should I let you go
how do i how do I do this
Oh God that was a bit you got it I'm
good I didn't mean to drop you on the
ground like a sack of bricks thank the
Lord you showed up when you did
so alright ma'am it's over now
thank you again you're welcome I'm such
a good person even though I just
murdered somebody but that's the way of
dough West if we are in dough West I
guess oh I got one I got one I got one I
can't believe I got one I got one
Hey look at me look at me look at me
look at me no don't skin it oh I didn't
want to get it right now oh god now it's
gonna be bloody on the back of our this
is as good as getting that legendary one
right this is just as good this is just
as nice twice as nice half as fun that's
what I'm talking about that's what I
always say okay got that
alright good deer pelt well I wanted to
can you get over here horsey I wanted to
uh I just want to put the whole thing
there but
oops come on you I'll stow this away
stow this okay there's the poop then can
I still get this good dear gotta bring
this back to camp you know earn our keep
what not
oh I did not mean to skin this here but
here we are all right don't worry dear
I've got a nice bed made out of your own
skin there that's that's awfully nice
okay back moving on okay I don't know
how far we are away from where we need
to go I can't imagine there's got to be
a different way to go if it requires
covering a lot of journey like this
maybe that's just a reality of the game
because the game could just be flippin
huge which the game is obviously
flipping huge but I mean like the
intention is for the game to feel huge I
think that was one of the like the
things a developer said about the first
game is that like it was very obvious
they've wanted to make it seem like you
were covering a lot of territory but you
in a sense warned it went from like
solid desert to snowy mountains very
quickly but here it's like this huge
expanse of land and you ain't got like
it's kind of reminds me of Far Cry 5 but
you don't have the helicopters to take
y'all around or cars
oh it's okay it's okay boy how you doing
you kidnapping anybody Wow Sorry Sorry
what the hell I didn't mean to okay look
listen listen ah
wait no hang on wait wait hang on wait
no god damn it get your oh oh god just
get okay this was uh this was a mistake
okay
I feel terrible about this this was very
much oh no oh no oh no listen this was a
mistake this was a mistake I just wanted
to see what it was like to hop over to a
horse I didn't know oh hi listen listen
listen listen relax relax relax
hang on well that did not go well
none of that went well everything was
about as bad as it possibly could be and
I am sorry for anything you know what
hey how you doing there it's gonna okey
[Music]
Oh No
okay can I just okay listen I'm just
gonna go I'm gonna go now go now no no
no no no I didn't do nothing what are
you talking about you don't know yeah
you don't know what I didn't Anna I
don't know what you did no one knows
what I did I'm a law-abiding man no no
sorry no no I'm I'm a good guy I'm a
good good guy hey is this Valentine hey
listen guys listen hey how you doing hey
howdy howdy friend how do you do you how
do you how did all you howdy do you
howdy to you and how do you how do you
do now how dippity zippity-doo-dah day
to you and you and you nice hat I like
that hat mister blue shirt there I like
that hat oh hey all right whoo all right
anyway why am I here
my in the right City I think I am pretty
sure there's somebody in here that I
need to talk yeah in here okay all right
it's good it's good it's good hey how
you doing there hey how you doing how
y'all doing hey how y'all do you want to
buy a white tailed deer hey I'll park my
Agera in the middle street don't lend it
come on didn't don't mind me hey how you
doing hey how do you do that I killed a
bear let me know that you guys know
about the bear I killed a
yeah you do unavailable to do to your
crimes Oh pay off my bounty at the post
office okay easy as that Alan's gonna do
that not that I'm admitting to anything
but you know I just want to clear up
this messy business as quickly as I
possibly can so I'm gonna do exactly
that not that it was me no lawman listen
and where is the post office
ah no post Oh post office there we go
okay easy peasy listen this is gonna be
cleared up lickety-split it's gonna be
cleared up in no time at all just cuz
I'm sprinting towards the destination in
the vain hope that no one is gonna
arrest me for my crimes does not mean
that I am admitting any transgressions
because I'm absolutely not and I'm fine
where is this post days at the post
office that better be the post office oh
boy I'm just so excited to go over the
post office you know how it is
it's like last day before it's closed
for the weekend I gotta get my letters
to my grandma sorry just wanted to run
an ear and full speed nothing's wrong
howdy just wanted to pay this bounty of
this random stranger okay thank you and
just like that crimes haven't been
forgiven good thing I had enough money
to do so all right now back to the
saloon excuse me excuse me part me Oh
both please thank you I just gotta get
back to the saloon see what they want
from this mission I got distracted
because I went like went off hunting so
much but man this game you're just so
easy to get distracted in because
there's so many things to do and it's
like so involved in every level like I
had the reason I keep getting in trouble
is because I think that I can just
experiment and goof around and I can but
I made an experiment and goof around
like I do in like other games but this
one yeah sometimes it'll get to you
times it'll be uh it's not a cat hey hey
can I help you guys here what the hell
well what the hell what the hell whoa
what the hell what the hell good god I
just got in here what the hell oh come
on come on what the hell I just walked
up he assured punching me and you're
much better at punching me dad he just
head-butted me how am i dead
well this is a load of crap I'm just
trying to I'm just trying to exist man
I'm just trying to exist and apparently
I'm just I can't even exist apparently I
can't even exist no one's even gonna let
me exist
I just gotta suffer every day of my
existence sorry just took a nap yeah big
goofs I'm coming back for round two you
still over by that tree huh
no you're not there anymore you're not
there that's alright whatever didn't
need you didn't need nothing hey kitty
whoa whoa let's all calm down here oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa yo ho whoa
let's just calm down I did not have any
intention of shooting that cat I just
want to be very clear to everybody at
home watching I did not have any
intention of doing anything like that
I'm just gonna sell a squirrel head all
right whatever god I keep losing my the
game just cuz I died
[Music]
friends pleased to meet you hello
toughest mountain man quiet Anastasia
anyone can tell this one is a [ __ ]
that's me all right she's a [ __ ] cat
and that's order whatever you say how
much you cost anyway wait that a nice
way to talk to you a lady oh I didn't
know I was talking to a lady excuse me
well you got a fine way with the women
amigo charm where's bill oh man I dread
to think about it wait whoa hey whoa
whoa okay I can't walk in two seconds
without being punched or somebody
punching me oh there is a block
[Music]
Oh apparently not okay you don't want
more mister teaching me how to fight and
the kidney and the teeth Oh Oh big big
big boy big man Tommy big man
Tommy why did this devolve into anarchy
I smell live my life enjoy a little bit
of sunshine everyone and again my hat
hang on I gotta get my hat here Javier
you got him you got him this isn't my
hat my hat go uh oh [ __ ] look guys I'm
sorry I'm really trying here and I feel
like you're judging me and I'm doing you
know why Breezer I'm trying my best and
things are things and you know it's fine
okay here we go I'm gonna get them
and any minute now and get the Hat
real quick and now we go and we let him
have it one of these hey tough guy in
the head
oh oh hello yes I do please hey pretty
boy pretty big yes
[Music]
[ __ ] hey
just okay I think I'm getting the hang
up there is ways to dodge if you like
and BAP hey will you do slap me oh this
is ridiculous
everyone does this and then I just get
free whaling on the ribs out oh okay ow
all right listen
[Music]
how do I counter
here we go here we go here we go here we
go there we go I think I'm in the hang
that I'm trying to counter him
intelligently Oh God
Oh God what the hell we gotta kick you
right in the balls yeah well I said it
and I did it I ain't gonna play with you
big man
BAM wham wam put a grouse fight just
goes to show you that fights aren't
actually as glorious as they seem
they're just like weird you won the
fight already surely that's enough no
business sir but please I beg you
man walk into a bar and then that's what
I have to endure oh look who we found
sniffing about Josiah on the very same
well I thought you'd gone to New York
and miss all this glamour you must be
joking oh all right I went to Blackwater
looking for you gentlemen
black not very popular than it seems Oh
Xavier Bouc ah I've missed you and Bill
looking as well as can be
gentlemen always a pleasure you're right
we ain't too popular in Blackwater we
left a lot of money there and young
Shawn and it seems Shawn you found him
yes I have he's being held by some
bounty hunters trying to see how much
money the government will pay them I
know he's in Blackwater but there's talk
of them moving
oh we step foot well then we're dead men
for sure there'll be Pinkertons all over
the place but if he's alive we got to
try and of course it's you they want
Dutch always is Charles go find out what
you can carefully
Josiah take Xavier Martha go get
yourself cleaned up join them when
you're ready what about me well exactly
what about you what does that mean oh
come on
yes the communal water barrel the one
that everybody dips their faces into I'm
sure that's just totally clean and not a
hill not a cesspool for every disease
disease breeding ground in
human history okay well ain't that nice
so what a beautiful sunshiny day why the
hell did I even bother coming to this
town it's been nothing but trouble since
I tried to come back to Valentine are
you the guy that stopped the fight here
what's your deal man what is your deal
I'm listening why are you shouting at me
why oh it's you it's me it is me I'm
just trying to help where I can sir or
interfere you would have killed that man
[Laughter]
[Music]
well alright seems like a good enough
cause all I will give I'm trying
people how do I give I'm trying I want
to give how do I get a screw it I can't
figure out how to give I tried I tried
my best it didn't work what I tried
alright horse where are you
orphans well you're not too terribly
wrong about that but you better get that
coughed at if you want to give this town
tuberculosis alright what are we gonna
do next now we got to go back to the
camp right because eventually we're
gonna go to Blackwater please does the
idea here
Leopold Strauss Kiran Kiran oh that's
right Kiran the guy I kidnapped okay we
gotta head back to the town anywhere so
it seems like we're done in this town
for now hopefully I can get another deer
on the way back but
luck with that every time I get a deer
and just end up dropping it hopefully
this time we're gonna actually get one
that'll be nice
it is nice the way they do it like now
that I've started to get used to these
controls I am starting to understand
I'll consider whatever I want a warning
what are you doing what are you doing
here fellows get lost you uh you looking
to start a fight here I don't know if
you can get the shot off wait oh wait
the tree kind of helped in there well
you guys fired first you guys did fire
first
you guys did fire first that was all
self-defense
what shot him in the chin well he had a
good amount of money on him wooden
miracle tonic
this guy had a miracle on his body who's
carrying it around what a fool he was
what a fool or the fool not offing you
just give me an opportunity like that at
least I got some aggression let out of
me don't feel so terrible about
everything that I've been doing now
maybe I can actually get a good kill
from nabo actually find myself a deer
you're all right boy that might have
been deer on the top of this bridge up
here wait am I looking at that's a rock
those are eyes no
goddamnit ah-ah
I just want no no there goes and there
goes and there goes some birds okay
there it goes god dammit god dammit I'm
just a goddamn idiot just flopping
around like a frickin fool where'd it go
there it is okay that [ __ ] god I just
want to dare I just want a deer did I
get it did I get it did I get it did I
get it okay horsey come here okay I'm
not gonna skin you it's just gonna pick
you up
just picking you up horses out a
whistling range horse out whistling
range poor so what's I'm at camp I
[ __ ] walk to camp yawning I'm just
gonna go hand-deliver it i'ma
hand-deliver it
hey guys guess you got a deer huh guess
who's the cool guy we got a good deer
it's me hahaha your friend Andrew arstan
am Stan I've forgotten my name but you
won't forget the fact that I got a deer
for you because I am the best better
than all the rest and you are not gonna
forget that anytime soon
are you guys no no no no across the
board because you know what's good for
you and I I'm gonna give you this deer
and shut up we're all done here
okay so anyway that is all for this
episode of Red Dead Redemption - thank
you everybody so much for joining me we
are now up ten percent of the way
through the 40-hour Game two episodes
10% we got a long long long way to go
for this game but I'm gonna look forward
to every part of it I'm about to fall
asleep my guy is like literally
about to pass out here so I'm gonna go
I'm gonna lay down I'm gonna lay my head
to rest and then it's gonna be the end
of it right now I'll shut up no no no no
no no sleeping sorry boss
can't hear you gotta sleep sleep till
morning so tired boss sorry oh sorry
boss maybe you'll learn to shut up boss
alright so that is off this episode
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye bye